I have to say this about John's working
about boys and their headaches that I
think that in a late 80s into the early
90s the hood was a pretty chaotic place
we all grew up you know understanding
our streets you know and so turf is sort
of part of the DNA of human beings I
think
but when crack cocaine came in all of a
sudden the turf was a valuable place and
when they started making a lot of money
slinging crack that allowed them to buy
guns in the and so the turf wars got
really violent and most of us sort of
said what the hell is going on down
there and we used to watch the Sunday
night news the murder news Bruce Neary
on Channel five hal fishman and it was
basically a recap of what was going on
and in the hood over the over the
weekend how many how many you know how
many gangbangers got shot and when boys
and hood came out it wasn't just this
innocent black guy who died in the in
the alley was Ricky Baker and all of a
sudden I think the whole culture sort of
shifted into understanding that the ones
the victims also have families they have
kids they have dreams they have futures
they have disabilities ad and it really
in a way I kind of think it was the
precursor maybe the first early
whisperings of black lives matter yeah
and in it so what I felt about the
script and then I met young brother John
and and we we made a great movie
together all of us made a great movie
together but we this movie has not gone
away from our culture and this movie
inspires our culture to this day
to add to that as an actor I feel like
sometimes people don't remember what you
say they remember how you make them feel
and at one screening I came out and
there was this young boy and he was
really young and it surprised me that
kids so young where parents let them
view this movie because that wasn't my
experience and in fact I didn't even
know what an IceCube was when I did the
movie but what happened was I came out
and this young boy was standing there
and he was crying and I walked over to
him and I said what's wrong and he says
I'm gonna go home and tell my momma to
stop calling me a [ __ ] and that
touched me I just I just have one story
about me seeing the picture that really
really was really a prophetic experience
for me and Steve actually was up there
with me remember we went open a night to
the Baldwin Theatre the Baldwin Hills o
bobl Hills there I saw the kid I went to
a couple places with the bomb theater
make sure nothing was gonna happen there
I went to the Chinese Theater when they
had three things some I stopped a fight
in front of the Chinese Theater on
Hollywood Boulevard right let me come on
now you gonna mess up my my career but
then we went but and I was there
Cineplex Odeon when everything popped
off when I get to sort Cineplex Odeon we
talked about the violence that happened
David around country but didn't happen
in the theaters that happened there was
something happened around the corner
from a theater or down the street
whatever they would attribute it to the
picture okay
and so because nothing had ever been
like it but it's observing that the
Cineplex Odeon Terminator 2 had come out
a week and a half before and poison her
was showing a theater that was only
seated maybe between two hundred people
right in the small multiplex is ever
right and you had all these kids outside
that really wanted to see Boyz in the
hood
right and so what going in you're going
to look at it and stuff right all this
kids outside and then people weren't
inside a theater looking at the inner
stuff and it's like it's like okay I'll
just
you know this hole there's a whole bunch
of whole bunch of Crips in there right
people in blue limit there was two kids
dressed in all red they're gonna walk in
and I said listen don't let them in the
theater let's say one of it don't let
them and it did I'm telling you they let
them in theater I said the 11 theater me
and my folks walked out and I um me and
my upcoming everybody got their home
left we're coming out of here boom
everything popped out because then and
after that the students got this the
security but going back to the ball and
here's my story at the Baldwin and you
really I think you went there when Aaron
and your son and everything at us and
they come up people come out theater
stuff and this girl comes up to me she's
all crying crying she's and she's with
her boyfriend she's like I just love
this movie you made this but I love
something it's such a good movie this
and her boyfriend who was like you know
he was just really really thugged up he
was just he you could tell he had life
on his face right and he just he why she
was she was explaining what he felt
yeah he wasn't articulate anything about
what her cuz he was looking off in space
like well what he just saw and then he
looked down at me he said you made this
movie he said yeah he said he's heard me
and then they walked away but it was
like one of the things like he just
looked it was like she was she was his
woman she was telling him she was
telling me what this movie meant to him
and his life and what he's seen it is
like that's really one of my most
profound moments it because it was in a
neighborhood it was right next to the
jungles it was like oh he's right whoa
you know